Google cloud makes it easy for teams to
get the cloud resources they need to
build and host applications but there
are so many tools and services that
controlling costs and managing your
organization can get tricky if not set
up properly don't worry we're here to
help beyond your bill is a video series
dedicated to helping you better
understand what you're spending on the
cloud and best practices for managing
your cloud environment on this episode
we'll take a look at how to organize
your GCP resources
[Music]
questions about resource management are
top of mind for many GCP administrators
in fact the most common google cloud
billing support requests focus on access
issues and confusion around tracking
payment for services to help you avoid
having these same issues we'll go over
some best practices and answer some
common questions such as how should I
structure my resources for effective
cost management and what's the ideal
folder structure for my organization
first let's start with what we mean by
our resource and then we'll cover how to
best organize them and grant access
resources are defined as any Google
cloud platform service such as compute
engine and bigquery and they can exist
in a hierarchy when we say resource
hierarchy or referring to the way that
you can organize your Google cloud
environment and how that maps to your
organization structure letting you
manage access and permission for groups
of related resources as you plan and set
up your resource hierarchy make sure to
consider the requirements for your
organization you can always change the
structure in the GCP console so start
with the simplest structure that meets
your needs and make changes as required
here's a diagram of what the different
parts of the resource hierarchy look
like let's start from the top and work
our way down everything you'll manage in
google cloud is under your domain and
organization they're kind of like an
umbrella if you're an individual user
with a G suite or cloud identity account
you may not have an organization which
means that some features won't be
available to you until you create one if
you're getting started with an
organization or if you're migrating
existing projects to a new organization
the organization setup wizard may be a
good place to begin the wizard guides
you through recommendations and steps
for setting up everything so check out
the link for more information
the domain is handled through G suite or
cloud identity and helps you manage user
profiles while the organization is
managed through the GCB console and lets
you manage GCP resources and access with
an organization projects belong to the
org rather than to the user that created
them org admins can see and manage all
projects as well as set of permissions
and policies that will be inherited for
different groups of resources this is
especially helpful when a team member
creates a project and then later leaves
the company each organization and domain
have separate permission settings make
sure to set up multiple admins
or use a group for each to ensure a
reasonable level of redundancy billing
accounts are under the organization and
track any charges for associated
projects a billing account has its own
roles and permissions so you can manage
users for billing related functions
billing account users can associate
projects in C spend while building
account admins can additionally unlink
projects enable billing export and set
budgets in addition only billing account
admins can contact billing support so
make sure to have more than one admin or
use a group and ensure your team knows
who they are
we recommend sticking to a single
billing account per organization and
making sure only your admins can create
new billing accounts you can do that by
removing the billing account creator
role from your organization in most
cases you'll only need one billing
account and creating multiple can make
it tricky to track down payments if you
need to deal with multiple currencies or
follow certain legal requirements you
may have to create multiple billing
accounts but don't forget to still have
redundancy for your admins when setting
up a billing account the admin should
enable bigquery export as soon as
possible
since the export data isn't retroactive
this way your usage data will be tracked
and ready for analysis using a variety
of tools we'll talk more about exporting
and analyzing billing data in later
videos the payments profile is a Google
level resource that sits outside of
Google cloud and is used for paying for
all Google services such as Google ads
or Chrome licenses it's possible to have
the same admins for your billing account
and your payment profile but make sure
that you still setup multiple
administrators or use groups in the
payment profile settings review the
preferences for notifications and
statements as well as ensuring that you
have invoice delivery setup for email
and paper invoices having multiple
admins payment methods and notification
methods will make sure that you get the
right information when you need it and
avoid any potential issues projects are
used for grouping any resources like
google kubernetes engine or cloud
storage a project can exist under a
folder so it can be grouped logically to
match your company structure as well as
inherit any permissions from folders
above it or from the organization at the
top projects can also have labels across
your entire organization which you can
use to horizontally group projects and
services folders and projects can have
permissions
you control who can create edit or just
view resources inside of them for
example you could set up certain users
as project creators so that they can
create new projects or just project
viewers so they can see what's being
used and view the costs for an
individual project the permissions and
structure are flexible and changeable so
you can organize your hierarchy to meet
your needs
here's an example of matching an
organization structure in this image the
first level of folders represents
departments the next level teams and
then products with labels for
environments like production another
example might be using folders for
environments and labels for teams or
folders for lines of business and labels
for applications a project can have
multiple labels but it can only directly
exist under a single folder for projects
labels and folders ensure that you use
naming conventions that are familiar to
your team these names are referenced in
the console billing reports and for
resource organization it's imperative
that clear and well understood naming is
used across your organization of course
the specifics will depend on your team
and your governance ultimately the
structure and naming convention are
meant to follow whatever works best for
your org taking the time upfront to play
in your resource structure for what's
right for your business can save you a
lot of confusion and hassle down the
road with that overview of the resource
hierarchy the next step is to talk more
about billing accounts and the payments
profile I definitely recommend checking
out the links for a deeper dive and for
more best practices around resource
organization in the next video
we'll set up a billing account go over
permissions and discuss more best
practices
[Music]
[Music]